it's Valentine's Day and we want to do
something special to make a perfume
something that will really turn all the
viewers on if only you could smell it
making perfume is pretty skilled if you
make really posh ones you need lots of
components so it lasts all day the cheap
ones just evaporate quickly once you're
out of the shop it's gone so let's see
what we can do and Sam has found a great
bottle and this is the bottle in which
we each going to put in something to
make the periodic table of videos
perfume I thought a bit laterally today
and I've got here a natural product
comes from ladybirds
and Lady birds use it to signal to each
other to tell them to congregate so it
attracts lady birds so this is called a
hippo terrine it's one of about five or
six molecules that they make and use for
this sort of thing
so I'm going to put this into a potion
if it works for lady birds who knows
maybe it will work for ladies just drop
that in there I'm going to use vanillin
vanillin is chemical that gives vanilla
its flavor I feel that this will suggest
chocolate and ice cream and make few
people feel really quite good it's a
solid so we've got to dissolve it in
something to make the perfume usually
people use a mixture of alcohol and
water as the basis of a perfume I shall
use my Mendeley vodka it's a nice way to
solid the vanderlin let's mix them in
this is citronella and and this is the
classic smell of lemons you know it's
it's that amazing zesty smell that
really really is beautiful but it's very
strong very intense so we don't need
very much of it valentine's Day is about
romance you know and the next molecule I
want to put in was
which it's quite nostalgic for me
because it's a molecule that I worked on
quite a lot not only is it in a bit of a
warm tone to the perfume but it's also
going to get in color and that molecule
itself is cinnamaldehyde so this is the
smell of cinnamon cookies and an apple
pie this is an incredibly intense smell
so here we go we're going to add it to
the mixture just a few drops
there's my contribution Brady let's give
it a bit of a mix and you can see the
color of the cinnamaldehyde already
starting to come into the mixture here's
our perfume so far and the thing that
I'm going to put in into the perfume is
boron trioxide probably know if you see
my boron video that I do have a love of
boron so on Valentine's Day maybe I'll
get a little bit of boron boron doesn't
usually come in perfume very much but I
thought I'd try and put a little bit of
a boron compound in say about that much
in there it goes which that's on fine so
I'm going to add some of my lunch which
happens to be about our chocolate so a
traditional Valentine's gift
so why chocolate well a course has got a
chemical basis and here's the compound
I'm interested it's called theobromine
there's no bromine in it it just happens
to be the name of the molecule because
the plant is called Theobroma so it's
it's very similar to caffeine if we swap
this hydrogen with a methyl we got
caffeine and how it works is very
similar to caffeine it makes you have
been a little bit faster and your blood
vessels dilate so you get a little bit
lightheaded just very much like falling
in love apparently so I'm going to go to
lab melt some chocolate and add it
because the even the smell is really
enticing okay I'm going to take a couple
of drops and add it to the love perfumer
a little potion one two three I think
the people who make real perfumes in
perfume companies are called noses they
smell things really well and in their
office they have a whole range of
different chemicals and they mix them
together to produce special effects if
you own the company you're frightened
your nose might go away to somebody else
take your secret recipes so the owners
of the company remove all the labels
from bottles and just put ABCD and so on
so the nose is never quite know what
their favorite ingredients are but long
as they state that company they can mix
the chemicals all right so I'm going to
add a compound called eugenol and it
smells quite nice so you can see it's
kind of a pale yellow liquid I don't
know if you can see there okay I've put
in three drops so what I'm going to add
now is I'm gonna add a little bit of
bling to a perfume so what I'm going to
add is some platinum so I've got what
I've got in here is a solution of a
material called hexa chloroplatinic acid
I think it's going to add a little bit
of glamour to the perfume because you
know platinum jewelry is obviously very
popular at the minute very expensive so
we're going to have the world's first
perfume that actually contains platinum
you
hey all right oh wow no she smells quite
nice I'm getting notes
it's flowery it's not unpleasant
actually I don't know if I I wouldn't
use it but it looks weird so I think
there needs to be something to cheer up
a bit given that we're talking about
Valentine's and love the colour that's
associated with love and passion is red
we've got here direct red 23 which is a
dye it's kind of a very dark color I've
no idea how much to put into this so
we'll just trial and error see what
happens if we put this in it went from
being this really horrible kind of
unappetizing unattractive almost yellow
color to something now you look at it it
looks red okay it's a bit maybe it's a
bit like blood but actually when you
think about love you think that red is
the colour of love you've got an idea
for the name of our perfume by the way
of course the perfume will be called
Mendeleev stream in the layers dream